you are watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
as we've seen in previous episodes the
field of Robotics has recently taken a
leap in dexterity
currently robots can run jump perform
backflips and respond to real-time
changes in their environment but the
thing that you've probably noticed in
all of these machines is that their
dexterity is severely limited when it
comes to handling objects with
artificial hands or fingers this is one
of the hardest technical challenges to
overcome but that's just beginning to
change engineers at the Elon Musk
founded non-for-profit open AI have used
the lessons learned in artificial
intelligence to teach a robot how to
handle objects as elegantly as a human
could in this video we'll take a look so
the goal for open AI was to train a
robot to perform a task without being
programmed to do so the specific task
was to get a robot hand to manipulate a
six-sided cube
moving it from one position to another
position so that a specific side was
facing up so how would you go about
doing something like this
well here's the problem with current
methods of using an AI to train a
physical robot training is often done
using reinforcement learning a method
where a machine learning system acquires
knowledge through trial and error
the thing is reinforcement learning can
take a long time usually amounting to
years of experience that's fine if you
want an AI to be a video game all it has
to do is just play the game at a highly
accelerated rate and then learn what it
needs to but if you want to teach an AI
a real-life task there are two problems
number one you can't speed up real life
no matter how much you'd like to and
number two if you did want to speed up
real life you'd have to create a
simulation that's so accurate and
realistic that it can be useful for
training
opened a eyes solution was to mess
around with the training simulation
itself they traded an accuracy for
variation first in the simulation they
first changed the colors of the virtual
hand and cube then randomized the size
and weight of the cube the friction of
the surfaces how fast the hand can move
and even mess with the simulation of
gravity this process is called domain
randomization and it proved to be a
powerful tool the domain randomization
gave the AI a better understanding of
what it might be like for a robot hand
to manipulate the cube in the real world
the system had enough variations to work
with that it can deal with the
unexpected in a robust way the open AI
team ran all of the simulations on
thousands of machines in the cloud the
collective knowledge was gathered and
optimized before being sent back into
the system for the next round of
simulations the finished trained model
had about a hundred years worth of
experience of handling the blocks in the
randomized situations
[Music]
some unusual things began to happen
after the system was trained the robot
hand became much more general in the
task of handling objects for example it
can rotate a wide variety of objects
that has never seen before to a
particular orientation when asked even
more strange was the fact that the
system developed human-like behaviors
like sliding and finger pivoting without
ever being programmed to do so
[Music]
open a is vision for the future is to
use this method to train robots to
complete a wide variety of general tasks
without human input in fact open AI
actually is some of the same algorithms
and methods to train an AI to play
complex games such as dota 2 and quake 3
in the quake 3 scenario the AI actually
exceeded human level and even could
collaborate seamlessly with humans
within team matches and you should keep
in mind that this isn't like the regular
bots that you'll find in games the open
AI bots initially had no idea about the
game and learned how to play just from
scratch the vastly different
applications for these algorithms hints
at the notion that general AI that can
complete a wide array of tasks may be
possible in terms of more direct
applications creating more dexterous
robots with the help of artificial
intelligence could be a big push for the
automation of manual labor while seeing
robots in healthcare the effect that
this will have on jobs is another issue
entirely on a different note maybe in 10
years
capable household robots may not be so
far-fetched and if we look at this from
a completely different angle it took a
robot hundreds of years to do a sliver
of what we intuitively do every day and
I find that kind of interesting so
what's your view on this let me know in
the comments section below and that just
about wraps up the video so thanks for
watching this has been - go go you've
been watching cold fusion if you've just
stumbled across this channel feel free
to subscribe and if you know someone
that will be interested in this topic
feel free to share this video with them
alright I'll see you again soon for the
next video cheers guys have a good one
anything
[Music]
[Music]
you